a quiet place top to the box office over
the weekend it opened with an estimated
50 million dollars in ticket sales and
that's around 20 million more than
analysts projected and just think they
had a budget North seventeen millions
already this is a hit the horror movie
is set in a post-apocalyptic world where
mysterious creatures with advanced
hearing hunt humans they are blind and
can only find their prey by sound the
movie contains very little dialogue
between the characters
[Music]
heart is beating Johnson not only one of
the stars he's a writer and director of
a quiet place John good morning but John
Dickerson wanna say I just want us all
to be quiet because I'm not quiet
something very bad is going to happen
it's very bad I know I just gave my best
review which is all that's the thing
because this is the thing John Krasinski
I was getting my nails done the other
day total stranger I go can I recommend
a movie to you I was at a luncheon group
full of women I go excuse me excuse me
could I have the tables attention for a
second there's a movie you must go see
bringing you everywhere yes I will go
with you everywhere and the reason why I
love this movie so much because I hate
horror movies - why do you I don't like
horror movies I don't like being afraid
hmm but the thing that you all do in
this movie that's total silence for most
of the movie so how does somebody who
hates horror movies do that it's really
interesting believe it or not I was
offered this as an actor first and I
said you know what I don't do horror
movies no thanks and they said you
should just read it it's about a family
who can't make noise and you have to
figure out why and I went well that's
the best one-liner I've ever heard and I
read it and truly as I'm reading the
script I'm holding a three week old
infant we had just had our second
daughter three weeks before reading the
script and so yes it's scary and I love
that people think it's scary but for me
I was reading a script about a father
doing anything he can to protect his
kids while I was holding three week old
so it was so listen I cried anything
already but I was so emotionally
connected to this idea so when I rewrote
the script I just buried down into that
idea so when you wrote it did you have
Emily Blunt in mind I had only Emily
Blunt okay and turns out I am not as
confident as I thought because I just
wouldn't ask her to wait the two ways
this went in my head where she says no
and that's a super awkward dinner
conversation or she says and in way
worse she says yes I'll do it for you
and the truth is I've been witness to
the incredible taste level intelligence
and dedication she has in choosing
projects and so I couldn't live with
myself if she did this as a favor to me
so I didn't I didn't ask her to do it
and she actually recommended some other
friends to do the part and then one day
she said can I read the script I said
sure and she got to the end of it we
were on a plane and I thought she was
gonna throw up so I was reaching for a
barf bag and she said you can't let
anyone else do this role and it was
like she was proposing to me I see you
saying what I think how did it turn out
in reality working together it's funny
we were really nervous because I think
because people think were actors we have
the same experiences we don't you know
she's usually in a different country
with a different director and a
different crew and so we've never
actually been on set together other than
popping in for an hour so so what
happened was we just I said we should
treat this project like we treat our
marriage let's just be honest about
everything right now is there anything
in the script you want to talk about is
there anything in these shot lists that
I made for her is there anything you
want to talk about so by the time we got
to working together we were just right
in it and I will say as nervous as I was
it was the greatest experience of my
career I will never work with someone as
talented as professional and as
unbelievably enthusiastic Wow Wow see
doesn't that make you well it also makes
me want to have dinner with them but
that's a whole separate thing okay we'll
get you my calendar so there were movies
that wash over you and then there are
movies that make you take on the
behavior of the people in the movie yes
which you have done here yes how
intentional was that and how did you
work at that we definitely knew that
sound would be a huge character in this
movie and we thought that it would be an
experience for people and we're really
excited about that I think that you
never know until you put it in front of
a live audience
we were when we went to South by
Southwest I kid you not I was cutting
sound and picture probably 24 hours
before we went to that Film Festival so
I would doom this audience as scared as
I've ever been in my career and to hear
people start to gasp and then hear
people stop start or stop eating their
popcorn yes and all of a sudden people
just start putting their concessions out
of just staring and it was one of the
greatest experiences in my career and
that the night before Emily said what's
the one thing would be great about this
screening and I said you know what if
they cheered at the end that would be
great she said focus on one thing not
the whole thing because you'll get
overwhelmed in it and she's the best
yeah and at the end and it jumped out of
their seats and screamed so loud that
Emily had to yell there's a scene in the
movie where you and you and Emily you're
listening to music together and so they
have their headphones you have one you
have one and it's it's one of the most
sweetest tender things I've ever seen
thank you I was a little irritated
because she got pregnant the movie but
that's a whole nother thing that see who
you all are dancing
tell me about that because how do you
keep a baby the baby's born how do you
keep the baby quiet so I was irritated
about that but go ahead it's the it was
one of my favorite scenes to shoot and
to be a part of but I got to say I was
completely overwhelmed in the moment
because when you're directing and and
and acting in it there's a lot of jobs
obviously and we jumped into that we had
the music live which I learned from the
great Cameron Crowe played music live so
that everybody hears again and so the
crew is hearing it too and there's this
moment where we're dancing you can't
make sound but because it's in our ear
we can hear it so we allow the audience
to hear it and it was just me staring
into my wife's eyes it was beautiful and
I looked over and we called cut and crew
members were crying and they just said
that was one of the most pure marriage
moments I have to go call my wife know
it'll make you cry it'll make you cheer
and I love Stephen King terrific acting
but the main thing is the silence and
how it makes the cameras I open wide and
view away a few movies managed even King
said you did a good job come on I got a
Gayle King Stephen King you got the rare
King book eggs let me tell you a word of
mouth word of mouth this movie's going
place thank you so much thank you for
coming this is great quiet places in
theaters right now and you can hear more
of CBS this morning our podcast in
iTunes app well this is smart this
morning